one phone two phones three phones I can
count yes Apple announced three new
phone stay the iPhone eight the iPhone
eight plus and the iPhone 10 so what's
the difference between these all let's
find out let's start with the iPhone 10
not the iPhone X the iPhone 10 and I
will believe it the future of the
smartphone the edge-to-edge oled 5.8
inch super Retina screen really is
stunning but to get that seamless screen
Apple deleted the home button
interacting with the phone without the
button definitely feels different but
it's pretty easy to get the hang of in
an app swipe up to get home want to get
to the app switcher swipe up to the
center of the screen and hold control
center swipe down from the bottom right
corner the phone also has dual 12
megapixel cameras and a glass back which
will definitely become smeared with
fingerprints but the real game-changer
seems to be how you log into your phone
without a fingerprint sensor yes your
face is now the password using a mix of
cameras and sensors located in here
Apple space ID creates a depth map of
your face and logs you in when you look
directly at the phone I wasn't able to
register my face and test it out in my
short time but I did observe the two
steps of logging in that seems a bit
slower than a tap of a finger but we
will have to see in our tests but I was
able to test an emoji yes using all of
that technology you can turn your face
into an emoji the iPhone 10 starts at
999 and will be available in November
but if you don't want to wait or you
want to spend less the iPhone 8 are
gonna be for you these phones don't have
the same edge to edge glass or face ID
but they have a lot of the same features
as the ten they have the new 12
megapixel cameras and like the 10 the
plus can do this neat portrait lighting
trick both the eights have the same fast
a 11 Bionic processors and graphics as
the 10 which are optimized for augmented
reality applications and they have the
same wireless charging capabilities
and yes still no headphone port the 4.7
inch iPhone 8 starts at $6.99 and the
5.5 inch 8 plus at $7.99 both will be
available on September 22nd which one
are you gonna get stay tuned for our
reviews I leave you with this me as a
talking head
[Music]